[Music]
wow okay let me just say it is an honor
to finally meet you sonic is it okay if
i call you sonic everyone calls me tails
you're probably wondering why let me
guess
because of the extra tail that's right i
should have known you'd get that cool
also what is going on robotnik's back
and who is clifford the big red rage
monster
that's knuckles the last of the echidnas
and the most dangerous warrior in the
galaxy he's obsessed with finding the
master emerald are you serious the
master emerald that's just a bedtime
story well he believes it's real and he
must think you're the key to finding it
red red lightning give me the wheel hey
what are you moving
[Applause]
oh i think we lost him
[Music]
we did not lose him we definitely did
not lose him
[Applause]
i got an idea do you trust me of course
not i literally just met you
what are you doing
[Applause]
we're flying
uh did your butt just turn into a
helicopter
a quadcopter oh only sonic the hedgehog
could come up with something like that